So, the answer is the first one. This is just
a number three. And we can get three from expression
by following this rule. Starting from expression, replacing with number,
and then replacing number with the number three. The second one
is not valid. And the way to see that is
if we start from expression, we only have three choices. We
can replace it with expression operator expression. We can replace
it with number, or we can replace it with a left
paren, expression, right paren. Since the expression we're trying
to match starts with a left paren, the only
way to get it left paren is to eventually
have this rule that replaces expression with left paren. When
we use that rule, what we get is the
left paren followed by expression. Now we have expression here.
>From here, we've matched the far left paren and
the far right paren. What we have left is this.
We can replace this expression with paren expression,
and we have paren that's replacing this expression using
this rule. And then we still have the
second right paren that we had before. This isn't
going to match here because we need two right
parens to match. And the essence of this rule
is that every time we open a parenthesis we
have to eventually close it. So we can't product
expressions where the parenthesis aren't balanced. So this
is not a valid Python expression. We can
produce the third one, this has many nested
expressions. We have three perens that are open, but
we have balanced and closed perens. And the
way we can derive this expression, we'll start
with one expression that's our starting point. We
use this rule to replace it paren expression, paren.
Now, we have an expression that starts with a one,
so we want to replace this expression with expression operator
expression. We still have the outer parens that we had
before. Now, we're working on this part. We want to to
replace this expression with a number and then with the
number one. We're going to replace the Op, the following
operator goes to times rule. That's going to be replaced
with times And now we've got to replace this expression.
We're trying to produce this whole thing, so we're going to replace
this with, using the parentheses rule. And we can keep going,
we're going to replace this expression
with expression operator expression. Eventually get
the two times and then do that replacement with parens again,
to get the three times four. And not going to fill in
all the steps here because they won't fit on the screen.
But I hope you get the basic idea that we can
keep doing the replacements, making complex expressions like this one. So the
fourth possibility is not a valid expression. There's no way
that we can get An operator in front with this
rule. There actually are rules in Python that allow us
to have an expression go to operator expression. But we
have two expressions here. There's a three space three. If
it was just the number 33, this would actually be
a valid Python expression. Not something that we can produce
with this grammar though. And the first one is valid It's
not sensible, or necessary, to have er, nested
parentheses like this, but we could always keep using
this rule, so we can derive that expression starting
from expression using the last rule with the parens,
and we're going to end up with paren,
expression, paren, close paren. We can use that rule
again, we're going to replace the middle expression with expression
paren expression. Replacing this expression with the last rule.
That'll give us expression surrounded by parens, and we still have
the two outer parens on each side. So we can have
as many necessary parens as we want. It's not necessary, it
doesn't make a lot of sense. We would never actually want
to write code that way. But it's still a valid Python
expression. So recursive grammar rules like these are very powerful. We
only need a few simple rules to describe a big language,
and the whole Python language that we're going to learn in
this course can be described this way.
We're not going to describe the entire Python language
this way, but what I hope is that you have a good sense for how grammars
work, and you can see that, even as
we introduce constructs somewhat more informally as we
go on, that they could be broken down
into these kinds of formal or placement rules.